non la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Olivier KIC pour le groupe de l'Union
[Applaudissements]
centriste vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues plus de 2
semaines après les attaques meurtrières
du Hamas sur le territoire israélien qui
ont fait plus de 1400 morts nous sommes
toujours profondément
choqués je tiens avant tout au nom du
groupe Union centriste avoir une pensée
pour toutes les victimes innocentes
parmi elles nous déplurons 30
compatriotes tués nous comptons toujours
également neuf Français portés disparus
dont une jeune femme qui a le statut
d'otage
nous soutenons les efforts du
gouvernement pour obtenir en priorité la
libération de tous les otages notre
groupe exprime sa compassion aux blessés
aux familles des victimes aux proches
des otages enlevés qui vivent dans
l'angoisse nous pensons aussi à toutes
les victimes civiles qu'ell soit en
Israël et à Gaza et à tous ceux qui sont
désormais dans la
souffrance nous imaginions avoir connu
des sommets de monstruosité avec les
attentats d'Al-Qaïda du 11 septembre ou
ceux de daesh le 13 novembre 2015 à
Paris avec les exactions du 7 octobre
dernier en Israël le Hamas
s'inscrit dans cette barbare compétition
des organisations terroristes islamistes
il a enchaîné massacre de masse acte de
torture d'une cruauté bestiale mais
aussi enlèvement de plus de 200 civiles
aujourd'hui séquestré les mots demeurent
impuissants face à
l'ignominiie nous condamnons cette
organisation terroriste et ses actes
avec force Israël est en droit de se
défendre et de chercher à éliminer le
Hamas qui a pour objectif lui-même de
faire disparaître l'État hébreux de la
carte dans un premier temps car ne nous
y trompons pas le Hamas tout comme daesh
ou alkaaïda viv dans la haine de nos
valeurs et viv vise la destruction à
terme de la civilisation occidentale les
attentats d'aras et Bruxelles qui ont
suivi nous l'ont douloureusement rappelé
on comprend dès lors pourquoi le
président de la République a pu proposer
aujourd'hui à Jérusalem que la coalition
internationale actuellement déployée en
Irak et en Syrie pour lutter contre
l'État islamique puisse aussi lutter
contre le Hamas la population
palestinienne de Gaza est aussi l'otage
de cette organisation terroriste qui
mène ses attaques militaires depuis des
installations civil rien ne serait pire
que de vouloir confondre le Hamas avec
la cause palestinienne et sa légitime
revendication à disposer d'un État
autonome le Hamas a franchi une ligne
rouge pour qu'Israël ne puisse plus
accepter le moindre accord dès lors
quelle solution adopt pour Israël à Gaza
déplacer le Hamas au Qatar ou les
Palestiniens vers l'Égypte ou la
Jordanie impossible aucun État ne
l'accepterait faire une barrière avec
une démarcation large de plusieurs
kilomètres éminé à l'image de la
démarcation entre les deux Corées ce
serait condamné la population de Gaza à
la misère et a laisser la haine grandir
en attendant la prochaine éruption
bombarder la bande de gazer de Gaza
indistinctement en exposant toute la
population palestinienne c'est le piège
tendu par le Hamas qui veut réussir là
où daesh a échoué et nous souhaitons que
la démocratie israélienne combatte en
respectant le droit international
humanitaire mais tout le monde voit bien
la difficulté car les terroristes se
cachent dans la population elle-même une
difficulté supplémentaire pour le
gouvernement israélien vient de ce que
l'organisation terroriste a le soutien
de l'Iran la déclaration récente du
ministre des Affaires étrangères
iraniens appelant à éradiquer les Juifs
et arayer Israël de la carte en est une
nouvelle illustration elle vient
rejoindre en tout point la doctrine du
Hamas la Russie jubile la Chine et le
banquier de
l'attelage vous remarquerez que pour ces
trois états Iran Russie ou Chine le
Hamas n'est pas une organisation
terroriste la situation est très
préoccupante si Israël bombarde Gaza et
élimine effectivement le Hamas qui
gérera Gaza en ruine que deviendra alors
ce qui sera un immense bidonville
comment éviter que toute la jeunesse
palestinienne ne tombe à son tour dans
le panneau des sirènes du Hamas avec
l'effondrement de l'Autorité
palestinienne en sisjordanie comment ne
pas craindre l'escalade régionale avec
le hzbollah proxy de l'Iran qui non
contontent d'étrangler le Liban est
susceptible de plonger le pays du sèdre
à nouveau dans un conflit avec son
voisin hier j'ai assisté à la prise
d'armes aux Invalides présidé par le
ministre des Armées Sébastien le Cornu à
l'occasion des 40 ans de l'attentat du
dracar à bérout où 58 militaires
français ont perd ont perdu la vie ne
les oublions pas 700 militaires français
sont déployés dans le cadre de la force
intérimaire des Nations Unies au Liban
la frontière avec Israël il serait alors
en première ligne d'une reprise des
hostilités ne l'oublions pas le rapport
du président Cambon et de la commission
des affaires étrangères intitulé Israël
Palestine redonner un horizon politique
au processus de paix avait anticipé il y
a un peu moins d'un an l'embrasement que
nous déplorons aujourd'hui la formation
du gouvernement de monsieur netanahou
qui allie la droite avec une extrême
droite composée de suprémacistes Juifs
tenant d'une idéologie expansionniste et
visant un État théocratique soumis à la
religieuse menace les fondements de la
démocratie israélienne il pose un
problème de morale et de conscience que
les manifestation hebdomadaire dans
l'État hébreu ont révélé de nombreux
articles de presse ont sonné l'alarme
dans une tribune du Monde du 9 février
sophie Bessis écrivait suite à la
sanglante attaque d'une synagogue de
semaines plus tôt d'un côté les
provocations délibérées de ministres
israéliens pressés de montrer aux
Palestiniens de quel côté se situe la
force de l'autre la montée d'un
désespoir mortifère devant la
dégradation des conditions de vie en
sisjordanie et l'absence de toute
perspective de paix dans la justice ont
conduit à l'explosion actuelle si rien
n'est fait elle risque de prendre des
proportions que nul ne parviendra à
contenir fin de citation une addition de
haine n'a jamais donné un bon résultat
pour les peuples il est majeur de se
consacrer dès maintenant à la paix
l'escalade de violence en territoire
israélo-palestinien vient nous rappeler
que la solution à deux états un État
d'Israël et un État palestinien est la
seule solution viable pour la paix je me
réjouis que le Président de la
République soit aujourd'hui à TelAviv
pour reprendre l'initiative politique et
réaffirmer une exigence que le général
de Cole éfoquait déjà de façon
visionnaire lors de sa conférence de
presse du 27 novembre 1967 mais il est
vrai que les accords d'Abraham ont
permis des avancées majeures auprès des
pays du Golf ils ont apporté ter une
nouvelle dynamique de normalisation
israéloarabe comme président du groupe
d'amitié France pays du Golf je n'ai pu
que m'en félicité ces avancées très
concrètes se sont traduites par de
réelles coopération sécuritaire et
militaire comme j'avais pu le souligner
en mai 2022 lors d'un colloque que j'ai
accueilli au Sénat en compagnie du
président Roger carucci mais si les
accords d'Abraham ont vocation à
promouvoir la paix aux frontières
d'Israël tous mes interlocuteurs du golf
m'ont toujours affirmé que la résolution
du conflit Israël aupalestinien restait
une priorité pour emporter l'adhésion de
leur population en ne s'alignant pas sur
les États-Unis en 2003 dans son
intervention en Irak la France a prouvé
son indépendance au Moyen-Orient la
France est un tiers de confiance
naturelle pour amorcer un nouveau
dialogue et un nouvel horizon au
processus de paix notre pays a soutenu
sans discontinuer le droit d'Israël à
exister et à vivre du en sécurité d'une
part la création d'un État palestinien
vivant dans des frontières sûres et
reconnu d'autre part il est vital pour
tous d'abandonner la stratégie de la
cécité volontaire et du dénis de réalité
à l'égard de la réalité palestinienne
pour Israël cela consistera à abandonner
sa stratégie de colonisation en
sjordanie et à Jérusalem Est pour la
Palestine cela signifie la fixation d'un
calendrier démocratique avec des
garanties de déroulement des scrutins en
sisjordanie Gaza Jérusalem est la France
doit être l'aiguillon afin que l'Europe
mette en place un nouveau dialogue entre
Israël et Palestine l'Union a débloqué
200 millions d'euros d'aide aux
Palestiniens avant le conflit elle doit
maintenant investir le volet politique
en plus du volet humanitaire je salue le
rôle de l'Égypte qui a autorisé le
passage d'une aide humanitaire vers Gaza
après de longues journées de fermeture
du post-frontière il faut en effet
porter secours aux civil Gazaoui qui
manque de produits de première nécessité
la décision d'une aide supplémentaire de
10 millions d'euros porté par la France
mérite d'être souligné vendredi un vol
spécial qu' voira du fret médical une
fois de plus la France répond présente
et les sénateurs centristes soutiennent
cette initiative être en empathie avec
les personnes qui souffrent et provoquer
la désescalade par la promotion de la
paix pour apporter l'espoir d'une vie
dans la sécurité et la sérénité au
prochearient telle est la démarche
d'apaisement qui je l'espère sera porté
avec succès par le Président de la
République je merci